can you just tell people for before we
get to the the chat really quickly um on
sleep because there's a lot of the you
know i'll sleep when i'm dead out there
and
uh that's just not smart so can you just
explain what happens in the body in
terms of repair when you sleep and what
is missing when you don't sleep so that
people have that lens
yeah um
i think one thing you said sleep when
i'm dead i think the
hustle
mentality is making so many people sick
and we wear it as a badge of honor and
society and we go yeah you didn't sleep
and you accomplished so much
and we are like professional athletes at
doing but we are babies who are just
learning how to walk at being and
so much of our health comes from being
right understanding that you can just
be and it's fine right you don't have to
be here you can be in your body you can
actually complete your work
from your body from your heart rather
than from your brain right and your work
becomes so much more powerful and people
connect so much more to it and i think
about how many people are just here
every single day they wake up they grab
their cell phone and they read emails
and then they get up and they think
about the list of things they need to do
and then they start doing those list of
things but then they forgot to do their
coffee and then while they're doing
their coffee they're thinking about all
the things they need to do for their
kids my god is this a way to live it's
exhausting i do it i'm exhausted
i know i i can tell your energy's a lot
like mine sometimes when i'm on the go
right like it's it's it's we're we're
very much so doers and we're really good
at it that's why we've accomplished so
much but i what i'm here to tell and
i'll get to the sleep thing what i'm
here to tell is people need to also come
back to themselves at least for a little
bit of the day and that's why i go back
to rituals you need to put your feet on
the ground you need to put your hand on
a tree you need to actually feel like
what does this tree feel like you know
what is the like energy of this tree
because we have that capacity i mean
listen i was i was with an indigenous
tribe in ecuador they are beyond that
capacity they talk to trees and the
trees talk to them like that's in our
capacity and that might sound weird to a
lot of people but
understand that the more connected you
are to nature the more you are connected
to yourself the more you're connected to
yourself the more you start healing
right the key
to healing is not complicated it's not a
it's not the perfect mix of supplements
it's not the perfect diet it's literally
coming back to who you are coming back
to your nature coming back to nature
right coming back to your emotional
authentic self that's the key it's not
really that hard but so many of us and
you and you as a christian your energy
so calm it's because i try to do that
daily and and i feel pretty healthy you
know i got some skin psoriasis and i'm
working through that but i feel pretty
damn healthy right so back to the sleep
sleep is a major major major contributor
to getting back to yourself if you wake
up in the morning you're blurry your
you're brain fog you're irritable
you ain't going to listen to dr g when
he says go outside and touch a tree and
put your feet on the ground right you're
going to be like i don't want to be i
don't want to do this i don't want to go
to work so sleep is where melatonin is
released and melatonin is one of the
most healing hormones in the body it
helps re-regulate your immune system
reduce inflammatory proteins balance
your hormonal system clean out the
garbage from your body
your lymphatic system especially in your
brain your lymphatic system is cleaning
out all the crap in the brain for the
day right you're restoring repairing but
that only happens if you're getting deep
sleep right and a lot of people i would
say
i'd be remiss if i didn't say uh to a
lot of people sleep with their mouth
open and they're not getting deep sleep
because it's giving the signals that
we're
like in sympathetic response all night
so i actually really love mouth tape i
put it on every single night and that
actually causes my mouth to close and
then put my body in a deep
parasympathetic sleep some people have
the monitors like the aura ring or or
the watch to actually see how they're
sleeping but make sure the lights are
completely off
no and no ambient light no street light
pitch black that's how the body wants to
sleep and make sure you're getting good
deep sleep if you need a noise machine
to drown out some stuff great you need
ear plugs put them on if if your partner
is rolling around and snoring have a
talk with them on how to fix that but
really really really important is to get
back to yourself because sleep is like a
huge huge pillar and i'm guessing you're
an advocate for turning off like not
having tv honest people fall asleep and
also are you are you big on like i had
read somewhere about any lights like
lights from devices can disrupt sleep in
a big way is that a thing
yeah bright light and blue light blue
light okay a bright light and blue light
even even if it's like even if it's not
blue light um any bright bright lights
are going to disrupt your body think
about how it evolved right like the sun
went down and the wavelengths of fire
was all we were used to at night for our
eyes right so how can we mimic that now
is it is it doable for some of you yeah
it then then put put on some candles at
night and turn off the lights or dim
them as low as you can but really get
into the practice especially if you or
your husband or your wife or your
children are having really big issues
with sleep start implementing you know
really warm lighting maybe some night
lights throughout the house putting some
candles on throughout the house if you
have dimmers putting them all the way on
low and just see how that environment
starts creating a place where people
start sleeping better if you have
children no phones after nine o'clock uh
you yourself put it on airplane mode and
then at least just leave 20 minutes for
yourself 20 minutes where you can do all
right i'm just going to do a little
breathing some light stretching maybe
i'll take a nice shower if you can do if
you have time for a bath you know what
is your thing that you do you got to
have a thing before bed right if you
don't have a thing before bed then
you're not creating the space to get a
deep deep deep restorative sleep so
that's one of my highest recommendations
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]